Hello and welcome to a special bonus episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈浪漫史是如何诞生的》特别加更节目。
I am Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am joined as ever by my good friend and how I met your mother co-creator Craig Thomas.
一如既往，与我一同主持的是我的好朋友、《老爸老妈浪漫史》的联合主创克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
And this is a these are episodes that we call general questions, general questions, general questions.
我们把这些节目叫做“常规问题”、“常规问题”、“常规问题”。
I was waiting for you.
我刚才在等你呢。
It's always a leg.
总得有个拍子。
I was trying so hard and I was going to.
我刚才拼命忍着，本来打算……
Hi.
嗨。
I was.
我当时。
Try it again.
再试一次。
This is just a bit of what we call general questions.
这其实就是我们所谓的“常规问题”的片段。
General questions.
常规问题。
We're never.
我们永远不会。
No, but that was a little better.
不，不过刚才那个好一点。
I think it's actually like Einstein terms, time, the time of the space, time continuum.
我觉得这就像爱因斯坦的理论，时间，时空连续体。
I think we did do it all at the same moment.
我觉得我们其实是在同一时刻说出来的。
We just had to wait for it to go into space and come back.
我们只是得等声音传到太空中再反弹回来。
Here's how I hear it.
我是这样听到的。
This is how we did it on the show.
我们在节目里也是这么做的。
I'm just honoring, and I know Alec, you created this in some of the ancient past.
我只是在配合节奏，我知道亚历克，你在遥远的过去就创造了这个。
But I say, that's a general questions beat, general questions.
但我要说，那是一个常规问题的节拍，常规问题。
There's a lot you have to just honor a beat.
有很多时候你必须配合节拍。
I panic in the beat.
我在节拍里感到恐慌。
It can't be too long.
不能太长。
You panic, you give too long a beat, Craig.
你一慌，留的节拍就太长了，克雷格。
Yeah.
是啊。
I know.
我知道。
It's I know.
就是，我知道。
General questions.
常规问题。
Yeah.
是啊。
See Josh and I are getting, it's Craig.
看，乔什和我正在，是克雷格。
We've figured this out.
我们已经搞懂了。
Yeah.
对。
I'll take the head.
我来带头。
All right.
好吧。
Someone, by the way, I don't know who it is.
顺便说一句，有人，我不知道是谁。
Someone put a, did a super cut of us fucking out.
有人把我们笑场剪成了一个精彩集锦。
Let's fucking it out.
笑场集锦。
Did you put that on Instagram or something?
你把它发到Instagram还是什么地方了吗？
I shared it, I liked it, I did something.
我转发了，我点赞了，我做了点什么。
I clicked a button.
我点了一个按钮。
Well, thank you for that.
好吧，谢谢你。
Now am I screwing it up?
现在我把它搞砸了吗？
Or am I a geniously, ingeniously extending a runner?
还是说我天才般地、巧妙地延长了一个桥段？
No. Who could say?
不。谁能说得准呢？
Well, you just want the bit to go on.
好吧，你只是想让这个梗继续下去。
Your comedy brain is like, we got nine seasons, yeah.
你的喜剧大脑就像在说，我们拍了九季，对吧。
I see it as material, I'm hearing it.
我把它当成素材，我听到了。
So we're following up with some additional stuff around episode nine, Belly Full of Turkey, written by Chris Miller and Phil Lord.
所以我们要继续聊一些关于第九集《火鸡塞满肚》的额外内容，这一集由克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德编剧。
And what do we got, Alec?
我们有什么，亚历克？
We went pretty deep on this episode last time, but let's finish it off and...
我们上次对这一集讨论得很深入了，但让我们把它讲完，然后……
Laning around.
瞎转悠。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, we did.
好吧，我们确实聊了。
We got a few questions here.
我们这里有几个问题。
Something that I'm gonna, I have a question.
有些事我打算……我有个问题。
I'm just gonna point out that once you, once we went to the store, We're seven, 11, where did Lily go?
我只想指出，一旦你，一旦我们去了商店，7-Eleven，莉莉去哪儿了？
I'm sorry, I didn't watch the show, I don't watch TV.
对不起，我没看过这部剧，我不看电视。
I don't remember what it was named and I've watched it many times, but it's a convenience store and so outside, so that's his name.
我不记得它叫什么名字了，虽然我看过很多次，但它是一家便利店，所以外面，这就是它的名字。
Do I do the convenience store?
我去便利店了吗？
There's a jail, all of a sudden I start going, how many sets were in this episode?
有个监狱，突然我开始想，这一集里有多少个布景？
There's a lot, there's a lot.
有很多，非常多。
I mean, this would have been a week where, see this is fun to talk about how amazing our crew was, how amazing our set designers were, amazing how things had to be jingled around and just like there wasn't it's a big sound stage stage 22 on the Fox lot still think of it as our stage I don't know who's there right now but get out it's ours and they would have to when we'd have this many sets almost surely have had to like overnight dismantle one or two of these sets to put in other ones right because you have all you have multiple spots within the Erickson the Erickson household Then you have the jail cell, you have the convenience store, you have the Thanksgiving, the charity place, where the food, the soup kitchen place, and that's two rooms, right?
我的意思是，这本来应该是一个星期，看，这就是谈论我们的工作人员有多么了不起，我们的布景设计师有多么了不起，事情不得不重新安排有多么了不起，而且就像那是一个大型声音舞台——福克斯片场的22号舞台，我仍然认为它是我们的舞台，我不知道现在是谁在那里，但滚出去，那是我们的——当我们要有这么多布景时，几乎肯定不得不连夜拆除其中一两个布景，以便放入其他布景，对吧？因为你有所有的……埃里克森家里有多个地方。然后你有监狱牢房，你有便利店，你有感恩节，那个慈善机构的地方，食物，那个收容所的地方，那有两个房间，对吧？
There's like a backstage and then they have Ted runs out and thrown the mushrooms out.
就像有一个后台，然后泰德跑出去把蘑菇扔了。
That's another, and it isn't everything else.
那是另一个，还有其他所有的东西。
I'm maybe even leaving some out that there's no way that all fit and just stayed there for three days for sure the set magic was happening.
我可能甚至漏掉了一些，因为绝对不可能全都放得下，而且在那种地方待了三天，片场的魔法确实在发生。
I always found it incredible that you would go home at night.
我一直觉得不可思议的是，你晚上居然还要回家。
You've come back the next morning and there's an entire, it's gone.
第二天早上你回来，整个场景，居然就这么没了。
New house built.
新房子都建好了。
Like it was extraordinary.
简直太不可思议了。
Like how quickly they would tear it one thing down.
他们拆除一个布景的速度有多快。
And also like, this is maybe for people who wanna believe a little more deeply in the fiction of it, might not please you.
还有就是，这或许对那些愿意更深信剧中虚构世界的人来说，可能不会让你高兴。
But, so you're in the soup kitchen, right?
但是，你在救济厨房里，对吧？
And in New York and you walk 20 feet to your left and you're in St.
在纽约，然后你向左走20英尺，你就到了明尼苏达州的圣克劳德。
Cloud, Minnesota.
克劳德，明尼苏达州。
And then you turn around and you're staring at Ted Marshall's apartment.
然后你转过身，正盯着特德·马歇尔的公寓。
And then you walk 20 feet to the left and you're in McLaren's bar.
接着你向左走20英尺，你就到了麦克拉伦酒吧。
One thing I wanted to say that struck me as funny that I forgot to mention, there's something funny.
有一件事我想说，我觉得挺搞笑的，之前忘了提，确实有个挺搞笑的地方。
And it's kind of a convention that people use and we've used it a couple times, I think I don't remember, but like when Lily has her breakdown in the convenience store, like it's clearly just like a high school kid, like with a job, like trying to do his best, you know, it's like, he's got this like sad person thrown in his lap and he has to suddenly be like a therapist to her.
这有点像大家常用的一种套路，我们也用过好几次，我想我不记得了，但是就像莉莉在便利店崩溃的时候，那感觉明显就像是一个高中生，刚找到工作，正努力做好自己的本职工作，你知道的，就像是，他莫名其妙被塞了一个伤心的人，还得突然装得像个心理治疗师一样对着她。
I think that I just thought that was really funny.
我觉得那个真的挺搞笑的。
I thought that guy was good.
我觉得那个家伙演得不错。
He was really good.
他演得真的很棒。
He was great.
他太棒了。
You are taller than described.
你比描述的要高。
I really love that one.
我真的很喜欢那段。
Right, and also the thing of like- This happens when Paul Erickson's are always telling everyone that Marshall's got this tiny little thing of a girl back into your- Yeah, but also like this small town, like everyone knows everything.
对，还有那种情况——这就好比保罗·埃里克森家总是跟所有人说马歇尔带了个身材娇小的女孩回你那——对，但还有这种小镇风情，就像每个人什么都知道。
Yeah, everyone knows everything.
对，每个人什么都知道。
Everyone knows.
所有人都知道。
Oh, you know, the Erickson's.
哦，你知道的，埃里克森一家。
It's just that the flavor of that was fantastic.
那种韵味简直太棒了。
Perfectly, you know, that was really good.
太棒了，你知道的，那段真的很精彩。
Would have been nice to learn his name, but we didn't.
要是能知道他的名字就好了，但我們沒問。
But hey, you're a good guy.
不過嘿，你是個好人。
You know who you are.
你知道你是誰。
Becky Strauss, 11 asks, can you talk about the inspiration behind Marshall's love from Minnesota and the Vikings and his two brothers and everything Marshall Erickson.
貝基·施勞斯（Becky Strauss）第11個提問說，能談談馬歇爾對明尼蘇達州、維京人隊的熱愛，還有他的兩個兄弟以及馬歇爾·埃里克森的一切，這些靈感是怎麼來的嗎？
Where did Minnesota, is that where Jason's from?
明尼蘇達是從哪裡來的，傑森是那裡的人嗎？
No, no, Jason's from LA and the character's little parts of the character, of course, based on me and I am from Long Island.
不，不，傑森是洛杉磯人，這個角色的部分特質當然是以我為原型，而我是長島人。
So now it was, you know, we had some Midwesterners represented on the writing staff early on.
所以呢，早期我們的編劇團隊裡確實有一些中西部人。
Was Chuck Tatham already on the show?
查克·塔瑟姆（Chuck Tatham）當時已經加入劇組了嗎？
Chuck Tatham wasn't on the show yet.
查克·塔瑟姆當時還沒加入劇組。
What's funny is Chuck Tatham, a very funny writer, joined a few seasons in and was as a Canadian.
有趣的是，查克·塔瑟姆——一個非常有趣的作家——在幾季後加入了，而且他是加拿大人。
He, from just outside near Toronto and Guelph, and he's a very funny Canadian as it's so often the case with Canadians.
他來自多倫多和圭爾夫郊外，正如加拿大人經常給人的印象那樣，他是一個非常有趣的加拿大人。
They seem a little extra funny and brilliant and he was those things and he but he had you know he's just over the border there in Toronto and there were people in his world that would be fans of the Minnesota Vikings.
他們似乎總是格外有趣且才華橫溢，他就是這樣的人，不過他呢，你知道的，他就在那邊的邊境多倫多，他的世界裡有些人會是明尼蘇達維京人隊的球迷。
Like there wasn't that huge of a trip to like you could get in there and sort of like travel and go to a Vikings game which he did a bunch of times.
這並不是多麼遙不可及的事，你可以去那裡，甚至可以去觀看維京人隊的比賽，他確實去過好幾次。
He became this lifelong Vikings fan despite being a Canadian and so everything about Marshall loving the Vikings came from Chuck Chuck Tatham was legitimately a hardcore Vikings fan since childhood.
儘管他是個加拿大人，但他卻成了維京人隊的死忠球迷，所以馬歇爾熱愛維京人隊的一切都源自於查克。查克·塔瑟姆從小就是個不折不扣的維京人隊鐵桿粉絲。
But why was Marshall from Minnesota?
但為什麼馬歇爾要來自明尼蘇達州呢？
I think we just arrived at it.
我想我們就是這樣決定的。
We thought Lily is a Brooklyn girl, right?
我們想過，莉莉是布魯克林女孩，對吧？
We don't want to hit Marshall also to be from New York.
我們不想讓馬歇爾也來自紐約。
We just wanted them to be from two different worlds and meeting at Wesleyan.
我們只是想讓他們來自兩個不同的世界，然後在衛斯理大學相遇。
We didn't want it to be too similar to Ohio.
我們不想讓它跟俄亥俄州太相似。
We knew we wanted Ted to be from Ohio, like Josh, Kobe's Canadian.
我們知道我們想讓泰德來自俄亥俄州，就像喬斯·科比是加拿大人一樣。
I think we just landed on Minnesota.
我想我們只是剛好選定了明尼蘇達州。
It wasn't because anyone from the writing staff was literally from there.
這並不是因為編劇團隊裡有誰真的是那裡的人。
We just thought it's a world.
我們只是覺得這是一個世界。
It's a world to explore.
這是一個值得探索的世界。
It's a cool other world and energy than we have in the group.
比起我們團隊裡原有的氛圍，這是一個很酷的、充滿不同活力的新世界。
So that's why we did it.
所以這就是我們這樣做的原因。
You know, it strikes me that you make these decisions and you might make them pretty flippantly or off-handedly, just like, it could be as casual as like, what about Minnesota?
你知道的，我突然覺得，你們做這些決定時可能非常隨意或漫不經心，就像——可能隨口說句「明尼蘇達怎麼樣？」
And someone's like, yeah, yeah, let's do Minnesota.
然後有人就會說：「對，對，就定明尼蘇達吧。」
Then you do a show for nine years and Minnesota becomes like a pretty consequential choice.
然後你拍了一部九年的劇，明尼蘇達就變成了一個相當重要的選擇。
Like, Minnesota fuels a lot of comedy, Minnesota is, yeah, it just becomes a bigger deal because of the longevity of the show.
比如，明尼蘇達為很多喜劇提供了素材，明尼蘇達它，是的，隨著劇集的長期播出，它變得越來越重要。
Totally, and it inspires whole episodes.
完全同意，而且它還啟發了整整好幾集。
There's a whole episode about finding a Minnesota Vikings bar in New York City.
有一整集都在講如何在紐約市找到一家明尼蘇達維京人隊的酒吧。
It's like, that's just because of some random, we sort of threw a dart at the map of America and arrived at that, and it becomes this defining thing about Marshall and his love of the Vikings and the flavor of who his family is, and all these things, it is amazing.
這就像是，這只是因為某個隨機的決定，我們在地圖上隨便射了一支飛鏢就選中了那裡，而它最終卻成了定義馬歇爾及其對維京人隊的熱愛、以及他家庭風格的核心元素，所有這些都太神奇了。
You are, TV is building the car while you're driving it, right?
你看，拍電視節目就像一邊開車一邊組裝汽車，對吧？
you're never ceasing to build the new parts of that car, but it has to also remain in motion the entire time.
你永遠不會停止為這輛車建造新的零件，但它同時還必須一邊行駛。
And it's that's kind of what's hard about it, and it's what's thrilling and wonderful about it too.
這就是這項工作艱難的地方，但也是它令人興奮和美妙的地方。
I always felt Jason had a particular glint in his eye around that family, like when those brothers would show up in the font, like, I don't know, I think one Jason, like he kind of got a kick out of being like the run of the litter because he's always the tallest person.
我一直覺得傑森在詮釋那個家庭時眼神裡有一種特別的光芒，比如當那些兄弟在片中出現時，就像——我不知道，我覺得傑森有點像是在扮演「最矮小的一個」中找到樂趣，因為他總是所有人裡最高的那一個。
And it was just, I could really tell that he enjoyed those Minnesota scenes, you know.
我真的能看出他非常享受那些在明尼蘇達的戲份，你知道的。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
That's three months old, baby.
那是三個月大的嬰兒，寶貝。
Yeah.
對。
It's like clearly one year.
這明明看起來像一歲。
So all of that stuff was so, so funny.
所以所有這些橋段都太好笑、太好笑了。
And Jason was energized by that story.
而且傑森也被這個故事激發了活力。
He likes the idea that he got to go be in this whole other world, but it's not his own world.
他喜歡這種可以去體驗另一個完全不同的世界、但又不是他自己真實世界的想法。
And that's, yeah, it's not based on Jason, even though Ted and Robin are both like, right?
那就是，沒錯，這並不是以傑森為原型的，儘管泰德和羅賓都是——對吧？
we made their hometowns match.
我們讓他們的家鄉吻合了。
Your guys actual hometowns.
你們大家真實的家鄉。
Kobe, you retrofitted it to her.
科比，你是根據她後續的設定調整的。
You made her from Canada after it.
你是後來才把她設定為來自加拿大的。
I heard it's from Ohio.
我聽說（卡特）來自俄亥俄州。
Carter's from Ohio.
卡特來自俄亥俄州。
It's from Ohio.
（他）來自俄亥俄州。
I stepped in and it was somewhat coincidental that I also happened to have.
我加入的時候，我也恰好（來自那裡），這多少有點巧合。
It's just his men, yeah, it's true.
這只是他的人設，對，沒錯。
I think it didn't hurt me getting the role.
我覺得這對我得到這個角色很有幫助。
But yeah, that's what I mean.
但對，這就是我的意思。
It was like so right away, you were also Ohio that it feels, it feels of a piece.
就像一開始那樣，你也是俄亥俄人，所以感覺一切都很契合。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you.
我為你寫了這首小曲子要唱給你聽。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡爾·拉德克（Carl Radke）。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock, and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能從Bravo電視台的《夏日山莊》（Summer House）認識我，但在我的播客《更多生活》（More Life）中，我將帶領你喜愛的真人秀明星們卸下工作，進入那些你平時聽不到的對話中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的事情、脆弱的事情、讓人感到不自在的事情。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我曾與席亞拉·米勒（Sierra Miller）、多琳達·梅德利（Dorinda Medley）、湯姆·施瓦茨（Tom Schwartz）、林賽·哈伯德（Lindsay Hubbard）以及許多其他人坐在一起暢談。
We get into relationships, growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我們深入探討人際關係、成長經歷、那些一團糟的事，以及攝影機沒拍到時發生的所有事情。
episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每週都有《更多生活》的新節目，請在各大播客平台收聽，或在YouTube上觀看。
I was noticing Kobe in this one who plays a very, um, a true straight man, straight woman, straight man, yes, ending the whole thing.
我注意到科比在這一集裡飾演了一個非常……嗯，一個真正的理性角色，理性女性，理性角色，沒錯，貫穿了整件事。
There's nothing she doesn't break in terms of, isn't it weird that we're here in this soup kitchen and bar?
她對所有事情都會吐槽，比如：「我們來到這家慈善廚房兼酒吧，難道不奇怪嗎？」
Isn't it weird that we're here in a strip club?
「我們來到脫衣舞俱樂部，難道不奇怪嗎？」
She just, she plays it so nicely.
她把這個角色演得太棒了。
Just, yep, yep, this is what we're doing.
就是，沒錯，沒錯，我們現在就是在幹這個。
along for the radio right now yeah yeah and a joe little ask of this is nice what was it like working with bill fagrbocky did i pronounce that correct yeah fagrbocky as a nineties two thousand skid i was just here patrick stars voice but he played marshall dead so well he was perfectly cast and he quotes uh...
現在正順著廣播走呢，對對，喬有一個小問題，這個挺有意思的：和比爾·法格巴克（Bill Fagerbakke）合作是什麼感覺？我名字沒讀錯吧？對，法格巴克。作為一個90年代到2000年代的青少年，我腦海中浮現的全是派大星（Patrick Star）的聲音，但他把馬歇爾的爸爸演得太棒了。他的選角簡稱完美，他還引用了……「飛機餐就是一團糟」，跟我們講講比爾吧，他和你合作了相當長一段時間，對吧？他不是演過《教练》（Coach）嗎？他演過《教練》，他是《教練》裡的唐伯（Dauber），而且他還演過《海綿寶寶》。
plane food is ass tells about tells a bill who was with you for quite a while well wasn't he he was on coach right he was on coach he was domber on coach and and he was in SpongeBob.
（缺失的173號對應內容，依序對齊）
He's so funny and good in that episode.
他在那一集裡真的超級搞笑又優秀。
And like, not to tell, this is the gossipy part of us and I won't name names, but we had somebody else cast in that role who we wound up letting go of very last minute.
而且——不是要爆料，這算是我們八卦的部分，雖然我不會說出名字——我們本來在那個角色上選了另一個人，結果在最後關頭把他換掉了。
To be Marshall's dad, it didn't work.
演馬歇爾的爸爸，行不通。
Like we were rehearsing for the episode.
我們當時正在為那一集排練。
There were some personality clashes, Josh, do you remember this at all?
有一些個性衝突，喬斯，你還記得這件事嗎？
Do you know what I'm talking about?
你知道我在說什麼嗎？
I'm not gonna name the names.
我不會說出名字的。
I know you heard it, yes.
我知道你聽說過，沒錯。
We're not gonna name names, but yes, there was another, Also another kind of somewhat legendary TV actor.
我們不會說出名字的，但確實有另一個人，而且也是那種稍微有點傳奇色彩的電視演員。
Yeah.
對。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Right?
對吧？
We can't name it.
我們不能說出來。
It would be crappy to name names, but it just, there was a personality conflict.
說出名字太遜了，但確實就是有個性衝突。
Kind of, it just wasn't fitting.
有點像是，就是合不來。
The energy wasn't fitting.
磁場不合。
I do remember coming in the next day and him being gone.
我確實記得第二天去的時候他就已經不在了。
And it being like, it wasn't like one person thought he should leave.
而且感覺不是只有一個人覺得他該離開。
It was like, everyone was like, no, no, no, he was dangerous to the help of safety.
而是所有人都覺得：「不，不，不，他的存在對大家的健康安全構成了威脅。」
Okay, it's fine, it was Kevin Spacey.
好吧，沒關係，那個人就是凱文·史貝西（Kevin Spacey）。
I'll just say it.
我乾脆直說了吧。
我直接說出來。
Yeah, but no, I wasn't there obviously for like when it went down.
對，不過不，事情發生的時候我當然不在場。
Or maybe I was because it was like a weird run through, but because he was, I don't think he shot anything, right?
或者也許我在場，因為那是一次很奇怪的讀劇排練，但他因為——我覺得他什麼都還沒拍吧？
He was replacing.
他是來頂替的。
No, he didn't do anything.
對，他什麼都沒做。
It was, but that's how last, like that's, that's why I feel like I have to talk about it and answer that question because we were in a freaking panic.
确实是，但这就是为什么，就好像是，这就是为什么我觉得我必须谈谈并回答这个问题，因为我们当时真是急疯了。
We were like, what are we going to do?
我们当时都在想，我们该怎么办？
You have to shoot this hugely important role that's probably gonna recur in series.
你必须拍这个极其重要的角色，他很可能会在剧中多次回归。
And think of that, it recurred beautifully in series.
而且你想想，他在剧中非常完美地回归了。
And there's big shit that happens with Marshall's dad later in series.
而且后来剧中马歇尔的父亲身上还发生了许多大事。
And you have to love him.
你必须爱他。
You have to love Marshall's dad.
你必须爱马歇尔的父亲。
You have to care for him.
你必须在乎他。
You have to know Marshall adores this man.
你必须知道马歇尔有多崇拜这个男人。
And Marshall is who he is because of this guy.
马歇尔之所以成为今天的他，全都是因为这家伙。
And boy, would that not have worked with the actor that we fired from?
天哪，如果换作我们开除掉的那个演员，这能行得通吗？
It just wasn't happening.
根本行不通。
It wasn't clicking.
就是没有那种默契。
There was, it was just weird.
感觉就，就是很奇怪。
And I mean, we probably got Bill Fagerbocki in the span of half a day.
我的意思是，我们大概在半天之内就找到了比尔·法格巴克（Bill Fagerbakke）。
We just reached down to him.
我们当时就联系了他。
I don't know if maybe it was like a last minute idea.
我不知道这算不算是个临时起意的主意。
Had we had that idea sooner, I feel like we would have cast him.
如果我们早点有这个想法，我觉得我们就会选他了。
He's so great.
他太棒了。
I don't know why we didn't just start there.
我不知道为什么我们不一开始就找他。
I don't, I wish I remembered it would be such a better story if I can remember, but we was a last minute idea.
我不知道，我希望我能想起来，如果我能想起来，那会是个更好的故事，但我们确实是个临时起意的主意。
We're like, yes, him.
我们当时就说，对，就是他。
Sometimes as an actor, I actually like to be the last minute solution to people's problems.
有时作为一名演员，我其实挺喜欢成为解决别人燃眉之急的最后人选。
because you don't feel like you're going up against every other actor in the world.
因为你不会觉得自己是在和世界上所有其他的演员竞争。
You actually feel like, oh, they're in trouble and I think I might be the guy.
你其实会觉得，哦，他们遇到麻烦了，我觉得我可能就是那个人。
Like I think I might be the answer to their prayers.
就像我觉得我可能是他们祈祷的答案。
So there's something almost nice about being the guy who actually just happened to be available when you needed him and it turned into a great multi-year gig for him.
所以，成为那个在你需要时刚好有空的人，这种感觉其实挺不错的，而且这最终也为他带来了一份持续多年的绝佳工作。
But it's kind of, to me it's like, however you get a role is the right way to get a role.
但在我看来，无论通过什么方式得到一个角色，那就是得到角色的正确方式。
Like that's just how it happened.
事情就是这样发生的。
It was meant to be in some way.
某种程度上这就是命中注定。
It was meant to be a very convoluted process.
注定要经历一个非常曲折的过程。
It wasn't like he had, I don't think he had come in an audition and we didn't cast him.
这不像是他曾经来试镜过然后我们没选他。
God, I hope I'm not wrong about that.
天哪，我希望我没记错。
But we, I think it was just like, he's great.
但我们，我觉得当时的情况就是，他太棒了。
Maybe somebody knew him, Pam, for I'm a new him, somebody knew him, and said, I bet if we called Bill, he'd show up in three hours from now and just jump in and yes and this motherfucker.
也许有人认识他，帕姆，或者我认识他，有人认识他，然后说，我敢打赌，如果我们给比尔打电话，他会在三小时内赶到，然后直接加入，并且对这个混蛋说“好”。
He had that kind of energy of like real like, like utility man on the team.
他身上有一种那种能量，真的很像队里的万金油球员。
Like we'd just do anything to get the.
就像我们为了达到目的会做任何事。
Yeah, so joyful and warm and everything you needed out of that role.
对，充满快乐和温暖，具备了那个角色所需的一切。
Susie Plakston.
苏茜·帕利斯顿（Susie Plakston）。
She was wonderful, always wonderful, I thought.
她太棒了，一直都很棒，我觉得。
She was such a good choice for Marshall's mom.
她来演马歇尔的妈妈真是太合适了。
She seemed like Marshall's mom.
她看起来就像马歇尔的妈妈。
I don't know, she just really, I know she's supposed to, that's her job, but she was wonderful.
我也说不上来，她真的，我知道她本就该如此，那是她的工作，但她真的很棒。
They were A-plus, they were A-plus, Bill and Susie.
他们简直是一流的，比尔和苏茜都是一流的。
And how about her take when Lily says she's not gonna take the name?
还有当莉莉说她不打算随夫姓时，她的反应呢？
And she's like, but the apron's.
她当时的反应是，可是围裙……
Like I made you a Mrs. Erickson apron, you have to now be named to that.
就像是“我给你做了一条埃里克森太太的围裙，你现在必须随这个姓”。
How will this work?
这怎么行得通？
She's so innocent and scandalized and are sort of hurt in that moment.
那一刻她显得那么天真、震惊，又带点受伤。
She's funny.
她太有趣了。
She's probably six feet tall.
她大概有六英尺高。
She was so tall and maybe a taller and hilarious and perfect with Bill.
她个子很高，也许还要更高，超级搞笑，和比尔搭戏简直绝配。
You just, I mean, we just, the casting gods frowned upon us and then smiled upon us all within 24 hours.
我的意思是，我们当时就是，选角之神先是对我们皱眉，然后在24小时内又对我们笑了。
And then we had Bill for the rest of the series and got to do some really emotional stuff with him later and God, were we lucky that he had those chops and that warms to merit, then you know, to support that storyline later.
然后我们在接下来的剧集里一直拥有比尔，后来还能和他一起拍一些非常感人的戏，天哪，我们是多么幸运，他拥有那种演技和温暖来支撑，你知道的，来支撑后来的那条故事线。
And I won't say what it all is, but.
我就不剧透具体内容了，但是……
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
I wanted to point out, maybe have you guys talk about someone that we don't talk about very much in this show, which is Ebben Hamm and the Stand-Ins and Ebben's cameo at the end of this, at the end of this show.
我想指出的是，也许可以让你们聊聊一个我们在剧里不太常提起的人，那就是埃本·哈姆（Ebben Hamm）以及替身演员们，还有埃本在这部剧结尾时的客串。
I mean, he was with you guys for the entire time.
我的意思是，他从头到尾都和你们在一起。
Evan who plays, who's so good as the sheriff or the jail warden, he's really good.
埃文饰演的那个角色，演警长或看守长演得太棒了，他真的很出色。
But Evan was the stand-in for Marshall, for Jason, right?
但埃文其实是马歇尔——也就是杰森的替身，对吧？
For many, many years, like since day one, he did all nine years on the show.
很多很多年，从第一天开始，他在这部剧里干了整整九年。
To explain what that is for people, that's the way when things are camera blocked and rehearsed and different things, Evan would sort of like do, you know, Jason would sort of step out of rehearsal and Evan would sort of do the camera blocking with the cameraman with lighting.
给观众解释一下那是做什么的，那就是在进行镜头调度（blocking）、排练以及各种工作时，埃文会代替——你知道的，杰森会暂时离开排练，然后埃文会和摄影师、灯光师一起进行镜头调度的排练。
So they would like to frame the shots, yeah.
所以他们会用来构图取景，对吧。
Yeah, but so much more than that too, because they ebb in and like Gita and like, we have these, we had a wonderful group of stands, Ron Niccolosi, may he rest in peace.
对，但不仅于此，因为埃本和吉塔（Gita）还有——我们有一群非常棒的替身演员，罗恩·尼科洛西（Ron Niccolosi），愿他安息。
We had all these wonderful people that were really part of the team.
我们有所有这些优秀的人，他们真正成为了团队的一部分。
The stand-ins are really a part of the world of that stage.
替身演员真的是那个舞台世界的一部分。
In fact, when we would do rehearsals and run throughs when we didn't have the actors playing all the other side parts, the stand-ins would play those parts.
事实上，当我们进行排练和过场彩排，而演员们不在场去扮演其他配角时，替身演员就会扮演那些角色。
They're actors, they're good actors.
他们是演员，优秀的演员。
Ron, Gita, and Evan, they were really good actors, and so they would run throughs in front of the studio and the network, and when they got a laugh, it was great, it helped our writing, it helped our performance of run throughs and rehearsals that they were so good, and then sometimes they were so good, we'd say, you're gonna do that part, and that's probably what happened.
罗恩、吉塔和埃文，他们都是非常优秀的演员，所以当他们在制片厂和电视台高层面前进行过场彩排时，如果能逗大家笑，那就太棒了，这不仅对我们的剧本有帮助，也对我们在过场彩排和排练中的表演很有帮助，因为他们太优秀了，有时候他们表现得太好了，我们就会说：“这个角色就由你来演吧”，这大概就是这么发生的。
I bet Evan did it at the studio network run through, and we were thinking we're gonna cast someone, we said, screw it, we're not gonna cast someone, we'll just let Evan do it.
我敢说埃文在制片厂和电视台高层的彩排中就是这么演的，当时我们正想着要找个人来演，然后我们说：“管他的，我们不找别人了，就让埃文演吧。”
That happened a couple of times, that happened with Ron.
这种事发生过好几次，罗恩也是这样。
Every stand in, I mean, Ron had a recurring role at the TV.
每一个替身——我的意思是，罗恩在电视里演过常驻角色。
Yeah.
对。
Ron was recurring.
罗恩是常驻演员。
Yeah.
对。
Well, I just want to say something about Ron, and he passed recently, and he was just a delight Ron Niccolosi.
好吧，我只想说一些关于罗恩的事，他最近去世了，罗恩·尼科洛西真的是个开心果。
He sure was.
他确实是。
And he was Neil's stand-in.
而且他是尼尔的替身。
And if you saw a picture of Neil and Ron next to each other, normally they try to get like same height, same build, like, because they have to light it, right?
如果你看到尼尔和罗恩并排的照片，通常他们会尽量找身高一样、体型一样的人，因为他们需要布光，对吧？
So they want the framing to be and not be like he's not an NPH type.
所以他们希望画面构图不要——他长得可不是尼尔那个类型。
He's not an NPH type.
他不是尼尔那个类型的。
He was not.
他真不是。
他不是。
He would remember he would wear those heel, like he had like four inch fat foreign heels.
你还记得他会穿那种鞋跟，就是那种四英寸厚的高跟鞋。
Yeah, like what Peter Boyle was wearing in young Frankenstein to try to get the heels high.
对，就像彼得·博伊尔（Peter Boyle）在《新科学怪人》里穿的那种，为了把鞋跟垫高。
To be the right height, he was much shorter than Neil, yeah.
为了达到合适的身高，他比尼尔矮很多，对。
And also when Neil, like either maybe Neil was out sick or something during a run through and Ron would do Barney, he would crush but in a totally different way than Neil because he had like a real New York or a Boston accent, right?
而且当尼尔——比如尼尔在排练期间生病没来或者别的什么情况时，罗恩会来演巴尼，他演得绝佳，但和尼尔的演法完全不同，因为他有一种真正的纽约口音或波士顿口音，对吧？
Wasn't he from Boston?
他不是来自波士顿吗？
Boston accent.
波士顿口音。
And he had a real thick Boston accent.
他有着一口浓重的波士顿口音。
So just a picture, a guy who doesn't look like Neil, gray hair, just crushing Barney, but in a totally different way than Neil.
所以试想一下，一个长得不像尼尔、满头白发的家伙，把巴尼这个角色演得出神入化，但方式和尼尔完全不同。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah.
对。
So funny every time to the point where he had fans in the executives, like the studio and network went through is sometimes Alex Jaffe would whisper to me, she's like, oh, I see that Ron's going to have a lunch.
每次都搞笑到甚至连制片厂和电视台高层看彩排时都有了他的粉丝，有时亚历克斯·杰夫（Alex Jaffe）会小声对我说，她会说：“哦，我看到罗恩今天要上场了。”
I want to hear what Ron's going to do with this.
“我想听听罗恩会怎么演这段。”
And she was like, oh, fan of Ron.
然后她就会说，哦，罗恩的粉丝。
And this is all to say that we loved Ron and the RIP.
这一切都是为了表达我们对罗恩的爱，愿他安息。
And Gita also, Gita was, I think, Kobe's stand-in, or what's she, Ali's, I can't remember.
还有吉塔，吉塔好像是科比（Colbie）的替身，还是——不对，是艾莉（Ali）的，我记不清了。
But Gita was on the show, she will, she'll pop up, we'll point her out.
但吉塔也在剧里演过，她会的，她会出场的，到时候我们会指出来。
He doesn't, you see Gita and all of them were on the show because they were all so good.
他没有，你知道吉塔和所有人都上过这个节目，因为他们都太棒了。
They were great.
他们太棒了。
They're such a part of the fabric of the show and they are good actors and they would score and run through and they'd help us out so much and then we'd often give them apart because they were so good in it or, you know, so there, the thank you guys.
他们是这个节目不可或缺的一部分，而且他们都是好演员，他们会记台词、走位，对我们的帮助太大了，然后我们经常会给他们分配角色，因为他们在里面表现得太好了，或者，你知道，所以，谢谢你们，伙计们。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Shout out to the stand-ins.
向替身演员致敬。
stand-ins and an R.I.P.
向替身演员，以及已故的
to Ron Ecollosi, who was a real heart and soul part of part of the team.
罗恩·埃科洛西（Ron Ecollosi）致以哀悼，他是团队中真正的核心和灵魂。
Oh, hey, everyone.
哦，嘿，大家好。
There's a little more.
还有一点。
There's a bonus to our bonus episode here.
我们这里的加长版节目还有一个彩蛋。
If you are watching on YouTube, you'll notice we're all dressed differently.
如果你在YouTube上观看，你会发现我们的穿着都不一样。
It is the next day because after we recorded our our general questions, general questions.
这是第二天，因为在我们录制完常规问题之后，常规问题。
That was me, honestly.
说实话，那是我。
So I just always thought about that one.
所以我一直都在想那个。
We got an email from Chris Miller with a little more information about this episode and we were able to match up his answers with some more of your questions.
我们收到了克里斯·米勒（Chris Miller）发来的一封电子邮件，里面包含了一些关于这一集更多的信息，我们得以将他的回答与你们更多的提问结合起来。
Chris and Phil were sorry they couldn't be with us.
克里斯和菲尔很遗憾没能和我们在一起。
We wanted to get them for that episode.
我们本来想让他们参加那一集。
Maybe we can have the two of them on for a special combo Lord Miller episode sometime in the future.
也许以后我们可以请他们两个来参加一个特别的“米勒勋爵”组合特辑。
We'll see their post doing post on another huge amazing movie and Chris wanted to make sure he threw in a few tidbits and that's what this is.
我们拭目以待，他们在完成另一部宏大惊艳的电影后期制作，克里斯确保他留下了一些花絮，这就是本期的内容。
All right.
好吧。
So Hannah Joe Little asks, have any of you ever been arrested for public urination?
那么，汉娜·乔·利特尔（Hannah Joe Little）问，你们当中有人因为随地小便而被捕过吗？
I'll start it off because I was in the writer's room with Chris and I will say that I forgot almost all of this and was delighted with Chris throwing this out there.
我来开个头，因为我和克里斯一起在编剧室里，我要说的是，我几乎把这些全忘了，克里斯抛出这个话题让我感到非常惊喜。
So he says, Chris's answer to that question is, Barney getting arrested was based on my brother-in-law, David Mergio.
所以他说，克里斯对这个问题的回答是，巴尼被捕是以我的连襟大卫·墨吉奥（David Mergio）为原型的。
You're welcome for the shout out here, David, who might have met in real life and is a lovely man.
大卫，谢谢你这里的出镜，你可能在现实生活中遇到过他，他是一个可爱的人。
the brother of Robin Murgio Chris' wife who is the loveliest person, but apparently one night, David Murgio, he got stopped by cops for peeing in the alleyway behind a bar in New York and was forced to do community service.
罗宾·墨吉奥（Robin Murgio，克里斯的妻子，最可爱的人）的兄弟，但显然有一天晚上，大卫·墨吉奥在纽约一家酒吧后面的小巷里小便时被警察拦下，并被强制进行社区服务。
Again, David Murgio.
再次感谢大卫·墨吉奥。
We love him, we love Robin, we love Chris, and that is a blame Chris if David, if you're upset that we talked about that, you talked to Chris I love that he's like full he includes the full name You want to check this guy out he's on LinkedIn Abhajah Iprakash asks love the thanks teeny I haven't tried it But would like to tell me it tastes amazing.
我们爱他，我们爱罗宾，我们爱克里斯，如果大卫你对我们谈论这件事感到不高兴，那就去怪克里斯吧，你去跟克里斯谈谈。我太喜欢他这样了，他包含了全名。你想了解这家伙吗，他在领英上。阿哈贾·伊普拉克什（Abhajah Iprakash）问，喜欢Thanks-teeny，我没尝过，但很想尝尝，告诉我它尝起来是不是棒极了。
I want Thanksgiving in my mouth.
我想把感恩节吃进嘴里。
What is that from well Chris Chris writes It's the thanks, teeny was a gimmick we invented.
那是出自哪里？好吧，克里斯·米勒写道，Thanks-teeny是我们发明的一个噱头。
So Lily would have an excuse for barfing that wouldn't give away the pregnancy scare.
这样莉莉就有一个借口可以呕吐，而不会暴露她其实是假装怀孕。
And I made one to test it out.
我为了测试它做了一个。
The bullion cube was removed after five seconds.
五秒钟后，肉汤块就被捞出来了。
And it was, as you would expect, disgusting.
正如你所料，它恶心极了。
I completely forgot about that, but that did happen, I think, in the room.
我完全把这事忘得精光了，但我想这确实在编剧室里发生过。
That was amazing.
那太神奇了。
Or maybe Krista at home, but yes.
或者也许是克里斯在家做的，但确实如此。
So there are many questions, of course, about the salad.
所以，当然有很多关于沙拉的问题。
And Takea Esshan asks, who came up with the salad recipe?
塔基亚·埃尚（Takea Esshan）问，谁想出的沙拉食谱？
Is that someone's actual family?
那是某人真正的家人
recipe.
食谱吗？
Chris Miller writes visiting Marshall's family was based on a trip Phil and I took to visit our friend Lynn Ricketts.
克里斯·米勒写道，拜访马歇尔的家人是基于我和菲尔去纽约北部拜访我们的朋友琳·里基茨（Lynn Ricketts）的一次旅行。
We're calling out everybody's name in here and her family in upstate New York.
我们在这里说出了每个人的名字，还有她在纽约北部的家人。
They made a seven layer salad that had mayonnaise and I think marshmallows and we thought it was like a foreign planet which is very much the spirit of what Lily feels.
他们做了一道七层沙拉，里面有蛋黄酱，我想还有棉花糖，我们觉得它就像来自外星球一样，这非常符合莉莉当时的感受。
The salad we made for the episode had potato chips, gummy bears mayo and more.
我们为这一集做的沙拉里有薯片、小熊软糖、蛋黄酱等等。
Yes, I remember everyone had some had cross paths at some point with some salad kind of like there's a lot of people in the room, but I forgot specifically this.
是的，我记得每个人在某个时候都和某种沙拉有过交集，就像房间里有很多人一样，但我具体忘了这个。
Lynn Ricketts, great salad, thank you for the inspiration.
琳·里基茨，绝妙的沙拉，谢谢你的灵感。
Samuel Perez, 1909 says, this is one of those episodes that looks fantastic while watching it.
塞缪尔·佩雷斯1909（Samuel Perez, 1909）说，这是那些看着觉得非常棒的剧集之一。
But with all the tall people in this episode specifically, how are what changes did you make to make everyone seem bigger?
但考虑到这一集里有那么多高个子，特别是这一集，你们做了什么改变来让每个人看起来都更高大？
And what are some of the challenges to capture Alison compared to the tall talent around her.
与她身边的高个子演员相比，拍摄艾莉森（Alison）时有哪些挑战？
And Jessica Wallace, XOX similarly asks, when you cast Marshall's family, did you just request quote the tallest actors of all time?
杰西卡·华莱士XOX（Jessica Wallace XOX）同样问道，当你们为马歇尔的家人选角时，你们是不是直接要求“有史以来最高大的演员”？
Chris writes, the big thing that we thought was funny was little Alison imagining giving birth to a giant baby.
克里斯写道，我们觉得最搞笑的一点是，个子小小的艾莉森想象自己生出一个巨大的婴儿。
So the episode was mostly about casting the tallest people we could.
所以这一集主要就是挑选我们能找到的个子最高的人。
So Marshall was the shrimp six foot for Jason Seagull.
所以马歇尔是身高六英尺四英寸（约1米93）的杰森·席格尔（Jason Segel）衬托下的虾米。
And we learned we got character payments.
我们得知我们有角色版权费。
Every time a character we introduced in our script was reused, so we were very excited to cast the brothers.
每当我们在剧本中引入的一个角色被再次使用时，我们都会拿到钱，所以能为这些兄弟选角让我们感到非常兴奋。
And every time they came back, we would high-five them because they were getting work and we were getting like a hundred dollars.
每次他们回归，我们都会跟他们击掌，因为他们有工作可做，而我们能拿到大约一百美元。
Yeah, and those guys really still need that hundred bucks because they've only each won one Oscar apiece.
是的，那些家伙确实仍然需要这一百块钱，因为他们每个人只赢得过一座奥斯卡奖。
I don't know that I knew that, that if you introduce a character in your episode and then they recur, you get a little.
我不知道这一点，如果你在你的剧集中引入一个角色，然后他们再次出现，你就会得到一点钱。
Yeah, yeah, we get them for this character we created Ted Mosley.
是的，是的，我们为这个我们创造的角色特德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）获得了版权费。
I think you should just sign those checks over to me.
我想你应该把那些支票直接签给我。
We can talk out a week and we can cut that part out right now.
我们可以商量一周，我们现在就可以把那部分剪掉。
Nope.
不行。
Apparently I don't edit.
显然我不负责剪辑。
We get people offering to edit this show all the time.
我们经常遇到有人主动提出要剪辑这个节目。
Nellit Win 4 says, this isn't specific to the episode, but I'd love to hear more about the music selection for him, yeah, and how the music supervisor job worked.
内利特·温4（Nellit Win 4）说，这并不是针对某一集的，但我很想多听听关于他的音乐选择，是的，还有音乐总监的工作是如何运作的。
I've sort of chosen that as a question to lead into this information we got about some music in the episode.
我某种程度上把这作为一个引子，来引入我们得到的关于这一集中某些音乐的信息。
This is what Chris says.
这就是克里斯所说的。
This is a story about the band, the 88, that Chris and who Chris and Phil were friends with and helped us out a few different times on him.
这是一个关于“88”乐队（the 88）的故事，克里斯和菲尔与他们是朋友，并且在不同的地方帮过我们几次忙。
And Chris says, okay, so I'll tell T it up since it wasn't the question early T it up.
克里斯说，好吧，那我来做个铺垫，既然这不是前面的问题，那就铺垫一下。
In Belly Full of Turkey, you hear the song Mr. Roboto, which is a hilarious song to be playing in a strip club.
在《满腹火鸡》（Belly Full of Turkey）中，你听到了《罗博托先生》（Mr. Roboto）这首歌，在脱衣舞俱乐部里播放这首歌简直太滑稽了。
I just love that I'm on Thanksgiving.
我就是喜欢我在过感恩节。
That's the song she's dancing on a strip club.
那是她在脱衣舞俱乐部跳舞时放的歌。
And the idea was gonna be that we would then, At the end of the episode have the sweet touching song be like this really sort of indie rock acoustic slow emotional version of Mr. Roboto and the 88 who are awesome dudes said we'll make that for you.
本来的想法是，我们将在剧集结束时，让那首甜蜜感人的歌曲变成《罗博托先生》那种非常独立摇滚风格的、原声的、缓慢的、充满情感的版本，“88”乐队——他们是一群超级棒的家伙——说，我们为你制作这个。
That's hilarious.
这太搞笑了。
We'll do it.
我们来做。
And they made like actually a really moving pretty sounding version of Mr. Roboto.
他们制作了一个实际上非常感人、听起来很美妙的《罗博托先生》版本。
Chris says about it.
克里斯对此说道。
The craziest thing is because of the Mr. Roboto reference earlier we all thought it would be cool to get the 88 to cover Mr. Roboto final scene Adam and Keith who run that band I think did it.
最疯狂的是，因为前面有《罗博托先生》的梗，我们都觉得让“88”乐队翻唱《罗博托先生》作为最后一幕会很酷，管理那个乐队的亚当（Adam）和基思（Keith）我想他们做到了。
And it's awesome, but ultimately their song You Belong To Me was more emotional, but I always regret we didn't get to unleash a cover on the world.
这太棒了，但最终他们的歌曲《你属于我》（You Belong To Me）更有感染力，但我一直很遗憾我们没能将这个翻唱版公之于众。
I still haven't and use it in playlists sometimes.
我到现在还没放过，有时会在播放列表里使用它。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yes, and thank you Chris Miller for sending us all of that, and we've got a few more questions answered.
是的，谢谢克里斯·米勒给我们发来所有这些内容，我们还有更多问题得到了解答。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请宽恕我，在纽约市，所有的罪过都被原谅了。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史是如何炼成的》（How We Made Your Mother）由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我、亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是“蓝色之点”工作室（Point of Blue Studios）的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米莉·布伦伯格（Emily Blumber）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美工由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）制作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》（NYC），克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供了额外的音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的Substack邮件列表并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的缪斯通讯（Muse Letters），在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的第一部小说，你也可以订阅我的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Fathers Society），同样在Substack上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何做出改变，即本节目为筹集先天性心脏病研究资金而进行的持续活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本期节目的制作得到了 Backyard Ventures 的大力支持。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，它会跳舞。